have you ever had to have a really tough
conversation with your parents well I
remember one like yesterday I can still
feel the knot in my stomach 31 years
later so just imagine me I was a fresh
engineer out of Michigan State
University with my first real job offer
with guess
what
my dad's number one rival you have to
understand I grew up in Flint Michigan
my dad was a GM guy all the way like his
dad before him his brother and all of
his friends they were GM
lifers but thankfully my dad was
satisfied with the fact that at least
I'd be working for one of the
victory now when my when my granddad
start working in the Auto industry and
in the mid1
1940s it was booming fun fact popular
cars at that time were the Chrysler Town
and Country hardtop the Chevy style
master and the Ford Mercury Woody
station
wagon it was the modern age of
Transportation now today we're
experiencing another major
transformation many are calling it The
Electric Vehicle Revolution
now with that comes unprecedented change
that will require us to build new
capacity and collaborate in ways that
we've never seen
before now the change begins with
sustainable products that provide better
experiences and greater benefits for the
people that use
them we will need to build new
capacities to meet the
demand support
infrastructure and build a responsible
supply
chain all while
collaborating in ways that we never seen
before with new partners like working
with Tesla to bring more fast charges to
more
consumers and now other manufacturers
are following
suit now I sincerely hope that people
leading companies like ours will work
together
collaborate and learn and help each
other
succeed now our goal is to become carbon
neutral no later than 2050 and our
carbon footprint is as big as
Australia's we know that we need to make
the transition to electric vehicles and
clean energy
fast
now with that to transition and to make
sure that we can get to our long-term
goals this is what needs to happen first
we must continue to make awesome
products that can't go
away share a couple pictures with you
this is my Uncle Daniel this is my Uncle
Willie they both drove premium foreign
cars for decades so you know I began to
work on them right away to make the
switch to
for so in 2011 I actually pitched to
them the Lincoln MKZ Hybrid
this vehicle had the latest te safety
technology it had an interior like a
fighter jet it had a smooth ride a
distinctive look 41 m per gallon and it
was built by an American company in
their home state of
Michigan and it was the same price as
the gasoline version but way better for
the
environment they each bought
one the lesson it
is we can't make the change feel like a
tradeoff we are building on the
strength of our current products we are
electrifying our most iconic Vehicles
first like the Mustang and the F-150
truck now tell me this is not a hot
car it's all
electric instant
torque 0 to 60 in just 3.5
seconds and look at that Chic
design but my point
is when we improve our vehicles to be
more sustainable we also have to make
them
better and there's no better feeling
than driving right past a gas station on
my way
home
knowing that I can get a full charge
just overnight now my daughter and her
friends are always bringing their cars
home on empty wouldn't be a problem if
they drove
electric now let's look at the F-150
Lightning the F-150 Lightning can power
your house up to 10
days imagine the impact on Rural
communities if they didn't need a
generator when the power went
out people who drive electric vehicles
can also light and heat up a
campsite they can charge up a work area
supercharge a tailgate
party and even charge another electric
vehicle now these are product
improvements that my grandads could
never have
imagined now with that with all these
new products coming in the
market next comes
capacity we have to build and invest in
new facilities and talent now that's
true for any industry transitioning to
Greener goals and strategies now I'll
tell you a few things that Ford is doing
but we're not alone in this
area in
Tennessee we are investing more than 5
billion Dollar in electric vehicle
manufacturing for trucks and advanced
batteries and all of our facilities our
goal for either they're new or old is to
conserve and reuse
water use 100% carbon free electricity
and send zero waste to landfill and
we're also investing in Talent we're
investing in Education and Training and
and we're also listening to the
communities where we live and operate
that's huge for for Industries like us
we have to listen to people other than
ourselves now I'll tell you in Tennessee
we've created more than 6,000 new jobs
and again we're not doing this alone as
an industry we have invested more than
$120
billion in electric vehicle
Manufacturing we've
created 143,000 new jobs in the last
eight years and 40% of that 40% of that
happened since the US government
approved the climate and clean energy
legislation and and again we're not
alone in this we're continue to make
progress but we're going to need to do
more we need to build
more infrastructure here infrastructure
is critical we will need charging
stations as as plentiful and convenient
as gas stations in the US we have about
145,000 gas stations and only about
23,000 fast charging stations in order
to make the move to electric vehicles
fast we'll need many many more now I'm
not saying we're going to need one on
every corner but we will need many many
more we need every Community whether
rule or Urban wealthy or
lowincome everyone will need access to
charging and the charging station we we
must bring lighting shelter security
restrooms basic amenities these are
things that we will'll need to move
forward and one hopeful move is the new
SP the new federal spending that will
allow states to deploy fast charging
every 50 mies along major highway
quarters now let's and the benefits are
are just are real let's take a look at
the
110,000 electric vehicles that Ford has
put on the road since 2021 these
vehicles have the potential to save 5
million tons of carbon em misss over
their
lifetime that's equivalent to CO2 save
by not burning 600 million gallons of
gasoline like my family before me I am
proud to work alongside my teammates in
the automotive industry we have come a
long way it's so gratifying to see
electric vehicles on the road to to move
from aspiration to
reality
to see plants dedicated to building
electric
vehicles but outside of the US in Asia
where I live for 3 years in Europe
they're way ahead of
us here's what we need to do to make
sure that we're ready for an all
electric
future we need policy makers to
harmonize environmental regulations we
need one framework to drive a resilient
grid
faster we need to strengthen the supply
base here and still create more jobs
here we have the
technology we have the leadership we
have the Ingenuity to respond to the
environmental crisis with
courage and I'll tell you
entrepreneurs Venture capitalists
manufacturers
everyone is beginning to understand and
take this and accept the social
responsibility to
build a future of electric vehicles here
and they are also seeing the business
opportunity before
them and I'll tell you as a person who's
dedicated my entire career to
sustainability the road ahead is paved
with promise
and it might surprise my dad it's not
going to be about Ford versus GM or
stantis or even the US versus Asia or
Europe we all have to work together to
build a better future for the next three
generations of my family and yours thank
you